und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber guten abend legte
bergisch gladbach jetzt münster 3
furchtbare serien von sexueller gewalt
an kindern darum geht es
kinderpornografie ist ein
verharmlosender falscher begriff diese
lebens zerstörenden taten scheinen
rapide zunehmen
dabei ist aber nicht ganz sicher ob es
wirklich mehr werden mehr taten mehr
täter mehr opfer oder ob nur mehr
erkannt wird von einer schattenwelt die
sich um den globus erstreckt immer
stärker und immer lukrativer vernetzt
mit dem internet als brandbeschleuniger
der ruf nach entschieden einem
eingreifen des staates streit über
inhalt sinn und ziel solcher maßnahmen
übertönt jetzt sogar das überthema
pandemie benjamin gerlowski berichtet
und dann folgen fragen an die
bundesministerin der justiz
vieles ist noch unbekannt viele fragen
offen im missbrauchsfall von münster
aber was man weiß ist schlimm genug
kindern wurde hier schreckliches leid
angetan das wurde auch gefilmt und ins
netz gestellt das leid hält wohl ein
leben lang die politik fordert seit
tagen maßnahmen sofort
es muss möglich sein für täter und
mittäter sexuellen missbrauchs
drastische strafen zu ermöglichen
nur so können wir abschrecken wenn
signale auch glaubhaft nach außen
gesetzt werden
nach aktueller gesetzeslage kann
schwerer sexueller missbrauch wie
vergewaltigung minderjähriger mit bis zu
15 jahren gefängnis bestraft werden und
anschließender sicherungsverwahrung auf
keinen fall jedoch mit weniger als einem
jahr die täter vom schweren missbrauchs
fall auf dem campingplatz in lichte zum
beispiel bekamen vergangenes jahr 12 bzw
13 jahre haft plus sicherungsverwahrung
bei sexuellem missbrauch der nicht als
besonders schwer definiert ist und bei
verbreitung von kinderpornographie
beträgt die höchststrafe zehn jahre
die mindeststrafe drei bis sechs monate
der mutmaßliche täter von münster bekam
trotz zweimaliger verurteilung wegen
besitzes und verbreitung von
kinderpornografie nur bewährungsstrafen
auch weil er sich zu einer therapie
bereit erklärt hatte und taten auf die
nicht mindestens ein jahr haft als
strafe stehen werden in deutschland nur
als vergehen nicht als verbrechen
bezeichnet
an all dem gab es heftige kritik der
druck auf bundesjustizministerin
lambrecht gesetze zu verschärfen stieg
heute erklärte sie wer kindern sexuelle
gewalt antut
der muss mit der ganzen härte des
gesetzes bestraft werden ohne wenn und
aber muss klar sein dass das ein
widerliches verbrechen ist und das muss
sich auch im strafmaß ausdrücken
bei tausenden fällen sexueller gewalt
gegen minderjährige pro jahr und einer
sehr hohen dunkelziffer scheint das
problem allerdings nicht nur juristisch
lösbar wenn wir kindern aufmerksam
zuhören wenn wir sie ernst nehmen dann
ist das gut in deutschland ist so so
dass ein kind im durchschnitt sieben
erwachsene ansprechen muss auf seine
note auf den missbrauch auf andere
gewaltformen ein erwachsener zu hören
glaubt
den kindern zuhören und gesetze
verschärfen
zwei wege die vielleicht aus dem dunkel
des missbrauchs hinaus führen könnten
die justizministerin hat bis heute
nichts davon gehalten aus dem vergehen
ein verbrechen zu machen und die
mindeststrafe auf ein volles jahr hoch
zu setzen weil dass kinder nicht schützt
und weil es manchen geringfügigen taten
nicht gerecht werde
hatten sie gestern nicht recht gute
namen frau ministerin ein seminar pack
lieber das ist eine daueraufgabe den
kampf gegen kinderpornografie und
kindesmissbrauch zu führen und deswegen
ist es immer wichtig sich zu überprüfen
und alle maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
können eben auch umzusetzen und deswegen
ist es wichtig das signal zu senden
kindesmissbrauch und kinderpornografie
sind straftaten widerliche straftaten
und es muss sich eben auch in der
strafbarkeit ausdrücken nachdem sie
jetzt für die spd dem zustimmen
die union fordert das schon lange kann
man damit rechnen dass diese
gesetzesänderung ganz schnell kommen
wird ich habe mein haus angewiesen
schnellstmöglich eine entsprechende
regelung vorzulegen
und ich gehe auch davon aus dass das
sehr schnell gelingen kann
wir werden sie es dann sehr genau
anschauen um alle fragen die in dem
zusammenhang sind eben auch mit zu
berücksichtigen aber ja das kann und es
wird auch schnell gehen
der hauptverdächtige von münster war
zwei mal vorbestraft bekam zweimal
verjährung und dann kam es zu diesen
karten er ist ein verdächtiger und nicht
verurteilt was wäre in diesem fall
anders gelaufen wenn es ihre
gesetzesänderung da schon gegeben hätte
diese widerlichen straftaten die in
münster durch hervorragende ermittlungen
ans tageslicht gekommen sind sind
schwere verbrechen sind ist heute schon
ein verbrechen und kann mit einer stadt
mit einer strafe von bis zu 15 jahren
geahndet werden mit anschließender
sicherungsverwahrung das ist auch heute
schon möglich ich kann den einzelfall
weil ich die genauen inhalte die genauen
details nicht kenne nicht bewerten aber
es muss klar sein solche widerlichen
straftaten müssen mit der gesamten härte
des gesetzes eben auch verfolgt werden
ich habe aber doch noch keine antwort
gefunden auf die frage
was eine umbenennung des verbrechens des
vergehens in ein verbrechen und eine
erhöhung der mindeststrafe jetzt
wirklich aus sicht der kinder die
geschützt werden müssen
in der welt verändern wird ist das nicht
nur ein austausch von etikette nein also
es ist ganz wichtig dass dieses signal
gesendet wird solche widerlichen
straftaten sind verbrechen ohne wenn und
aber und das werden wir aussenden
aber es hat eben auch zur folge dass er
der straff rahmen der möglich ist auch
ausgenutzt wird genutzt wird von
richterinnen und richtern und diese
erwartung habe ich eben auch das
gezielte auch entsprechend der schwere
der tat urteile verhängt werden ist
nicht überhaupt das justizministerium
die falsche ansprüche dieser täter
bekennen sich dann später dazu dass sie
mit ihren trieben mit ihren
veranlagungen nicht zurechtkamen
verzweifeln an ihren eigenen tun und
wären durch für härtere strafen und
nicht mal durch bessere aufklärung
abzuschrecken gewesen musste mich an
ganz anderer stelle der staat viel
massiver seine kinder schützen
der kampf für unsere kinder und gegen
diese widerlichen straftaten ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
dazu gehört dass auch prävention
beispielsweise zu stärken kinder stark
zu machen aber auch eltern zu
sensibilisieren erzieher lehrer das
oberfeld dass wir noch sensibler auf
reaktionen auf signale von kindern
reagieren
beratungsstellen entsprechend zur
verfügung stellen stehen beispielsweise
was tun sie jetzt konkret als
justizministerin in dieser richtung ich
werde alsbald ein gespräch führen einen
dialog führen mitverantwortlich mit
politisch verantwortlichen sowohl aus
der polizei aus der justiz aber eben
auch aus der prävention mit dem kindes
mit dem beauftragten gegen
kindesmissbrauch
wir werden uns zusammensetzen und alle
möglichkeiten erörtern die wir haben
unsere kinder noch besser zu schützen
das heißt das steht am anfang das ist
nicht vollendet dann kann das ist eine
dauerhafte aufgabe ich habe gerade vor
einigen wochen eine bessere möglichkeit
für ermittler beispielsweise
gesetze gesetzgeberisch geschaffen damit
die auf veränderungen dieser dieser
täter reagieren können und zum beispiel
im netz besser ermitteln können und
diese entwicklung der müssen wir uns
stellen deswegen es ist eine
daueraufgabe und genauso begreife ich es
auch danke für das gespräch und einen
guten abend ich danke ihnen das gespräch
führten wir vor einer stunde und ich
bitte um entschuldigung für einen
versprecher der aus bewährung sind
obwohl loser weise verehrung machte
mitarbeiter der lufthansa bekam in den
nachrichten heute erschreckende zahlen
genannt die turbulenzen aus der pandemie
schütteln ihren arbeitgeber durch 22.000
vollzeitarbeitsplätze werden wohl
verloren gehen die mitarbeiter
reagierten erschrocken aber nicht mit
protest sondern mit der bereitschaft an
einer lösung mitzuarbeiten durch
verzicht einer ja nicht ganz
selbstverständliche nachricht peter
wagner berichtet aus rollfeldern sind
parkplätze geworden aus dem stolzen
kranich eine flügellahme bodenbrüter die
lufthansa kämpft corona infiziert ums
überleben
9 milliarden rettungspaket hat der bund
versprochen aber um dieses geld
zurückzahlen zu können müssen die
gewerkschaften mit ins boot es geht um
zehntausende arbeitsplätze von insgesamt
763 jets der lufthansa stehen derzeit
700 am boden 2021 werden noch 300
geparkt sein 2022 noch 200 und nach der
krise ist die flotte um 106 kleiner das
entspricht 22.000 vollzeit
arbeitsplätzen im konzern weniger an
bord und am boden
wir haben ganz viele maßnahmen
ausgetauscht und wir sind zuversichtlich
dass man mit diesen maßnahmen
sozialverträglich etwas hinbekommt genug
ein spanisches für lufthansa genug
jobgarantie für die mitarbeiter
die flugbegleiter vermitteln zuversicht
machen aber eines deutlich ihre
einkommen sind meist zu gering um noch
auf viel verzichten zu können anders die
piloten mit ihren meist deutlich höheren
gehältern die pilotinnen und piloten der
lufthansa sind sich ihrer verantwortung
bewusst und haben zugeständnisse in höhe
von 350 millionen euro angeboten
für den einzelnen piloten bedeutet dies
ein gehaltsverzicht von bis zu 45% der
gesprächsbereitschaft der gewerkschaften
begegnet die lufthansa mit einem eher
trockenen statement ohne signifikante
senkung der personalkosten während der
krise verpassen wir die chance eines
besseren restarts aus der krise und
riskieren dass die lufthansa group
deutlich geschwächt aus der krise
hervorgeht dass lufthansa personal
bekommt rückenwind von der opposition in
berlin
die lufthansa soll mit 9 milliarden
öffentlichen geldern unterstützt werden
und ich bin der auffassung wir sind der
auffassung dass mit diesen geldern keine
massenentlassungen finanziert werden
dürfen für tausende von arbeitsplätzen
sind gefährdet wie es besser gehen kann
zeigt frankreich bei der airforce wurde
mit öffentlichem geld dafür gesagt dass
sowohl beschäftigung als auch ökologie
besser dastehen als bei uns das ziel in
den verhandlungen bei lufthansa
möglichst keine betriebsbedingten
kündigungen das wird sehr viel
flexibilität von allen seiten erfordern
dass das auch gelingt auf der anderen
seite geht es da in vielen fällen auch
um sehr qualifizierte langjährigen
mitarbeiter bei denen es durchaus
sinnvoll ist sie an bord gehalten
in zwei wochen stimmt die virtuelle
hauptversammlung über das hilfspaket ab
bis dahin muss lufthansa-chef spor die
gewerkschaften im boot haben sonst
bleibt der rettungsweg verschlossen
die lufthansa ist ein teil der
realwirtschaft die leidet überall
während die finanzmärkte sich von dem
geschehen völlig abzukoppeln schienen in
deutschland in europa und in den usa
waren die börsenkurse zeit wochen auf
dem weg nach oben als wären lockdown
corona und eine mögliche zweite welle
ängste von gestern
von wegen der dax in frankfurt fiel
heute den vierten tag in folge -
viereinhalb prozent an der wall street
ist die richtung wohl dieselbe johannes
da gibt es möglicherweise ein
zusammenhang
ja gibt's im großen zusammenhang muss
das auch glaube ich im großen
zusammenhang sehen die börsen sind ja im
märz dramatisch eingebrochenen hier in
amerika hat man dann ein gigantischer
überall auf der welt gigantische
rettungspakete geschnürt billionen
dollar in den markt geworfen und das
viele geld wurde dann in aktien
investiert und das obwohl sich das ganze
mit der realwirtschaft überhaupt nicht
in einklang bringen bis 40 millionen
arbeitslose hier ein brechen der
unternehmensgewinne aber die leute
hatten hier die anleger hatten hier
darauf gewettet dass ist eine kurze
harte krise wird mit einem schnellen
aufschwung und dann sind verschiedene
dinge jetzt die letzten tage passiert
der notenbankchef hat gäste mit einem
statement den markt verunsichert in dem
er gesagt hat dass die auswirkungen auf
die arbeitswelt auf die wirtschaft hier
möglicherweise sehr viel länger und sehr
viel nachhaltiger sein werden als
bislang gedacht und dann kam heute
morgen die schock nachricht dass die
infektionszahlen die kurve
infektionszahlen unten im süden in texas
und arizona sprunghaft ansteigen
das arizona hat gesagt dass man zb
wahrscheinlich bald schon die
kapazitätsgrenzen der krankenhäuser
erreicht haben wird und da sind die
anleger ausgestiegen und dabei haben
doch die letzten arbeitsmarktzahlen
geradezu sensationell positiv gewirkt
mann war überrascht und hat sich viel
hoffnung gemacht
ja der präsident hatte letzte woche
arbeitsmarkt zahl präsentiert
zweieinhalb millionen neuer
arbeitsplätze das hat den markt eher
angeheizt leute haben das gefühl gehabt
jetzt geht es aufwärts
es wird nur eine kurze krise seien aber
dann hat sich leider herausgestellt dass
die zahlen völlig falsch waren dass man
die viereinhalb millionen arbeitslose in
die falsche spalte eingetragen hatte und
dass es in wirklichkeit nicht mehr
arbeit geschaffen worden ist sondern
mehr arbeitslose geschaffen worden sind
die regierung wollte das nicht
kommentieren hat gesagt wenn sie das
täten dann würde sie zugeben dass man
hier den markt manipulieren wollte aber
tatsache ist die zahlen stimmen schlicht
und einfach nicht und hier setzt sich
mittlerweile langsam durch das die
regierung wohl mit zahlen
das problematische umgeht enttäuschte
märkte sind fallende merkel
dankeschön johannes und die nachrichten
bleiben zunächst in den usa
ja dort in den usa gehen die proteste
gegen rassismus weiter sie richten sich
nun gegen symbole die aus sicht der
demonstranten für ungleichheit und
unterwerfung stehen wie
das denkmal des seefahrers columbus in
minnesota er habe mit der entdeckung
amerikas den weg für den sklavenhandel
geebnet kritisieren die demonstranten in
mehreren us-städten wurden statuen von
führern der südstaaten beschädigt wie
vor etwa 150 jahren gegen die
abschaffung der sklaverei kämpften
beobachter sehen in den protesten heute
einen kulturkampf in folge des
gewaltsamen todes des afro amerikaners
george freut us-präsident trump hat
mitarbeitern des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs in den haag mit
sanktionen gedroht sollten sie
ermittlungen gegen us sicherheitskräfte
aufnehmen dabei geht es um mögliche
kriegsverbrechen in afghanistan
trump will die aus seiner sicht
ungerechtfertigte verfolgung von
us-bürgern verhindern
die usa sind kein vertragsstaat des
internationalen gerichtshofes und lehnen
diesen seit jahren strikt ab die zahl
der menschen die beim untergang eines
flüchtlingsbootes vor der küste
tunesiens gestorben sind ist auf 45
gestiegen nach angaben lokaler behörden
sind mindestens 23 frauen und zwei
kinder unter den opfern
die suche nach vermissten gehe weiter
das boot soll mit mehr als 50 menschen
vor der ostküste tunesiens in richtung
italien aufgebrochen sein
als es anfang der woche sank im globalen
wettlauf um einen corona impfstoff will
sich die eu kommission durch vorverträge
mit pharmafirmen einen schnellen zugriff
sichern
sie rechnet damit dass impfstoffe für
300 millionen europäer beschafft werden
müssen
für die entwicklung entsprechen der
mittel soll zb die deutsche firma
biontech bis zu 100 millionen euro als
kredit von der europäischen
investitionsbank bekommen
in russland ist die zahl der korona
infizierten auf über 500.000 gestiegen
innerhalb eines tages kamen mehr als
8700 neue fälle hinzu die meisten
infektionen gibt es in der hauptstadt
moskau
die tests dort wurden inzwischen
ausgeweitet
landesweit ist jedoch von einer deutlich
höheren dunkelziffer auszugehen
insgesamt starben in russland bislang
mehr als 6500 menschen in verbindung mit
dem virus wenden die korona pandemie
auch eine gute seite hat dann ist es
wohl die dass wir erkennen was alles
möglich ist eine rasante kurskorrektur
wenn eine große gefahr erkannt und
anerkannt ist
individuelle und organisator
organisierte klimaschützer schöpfen
daraus zuversicht auf die lange sicht
aktuell müssten sich folgendes großen
lockdown zeigen
dazu präsentierte die
bundesumweltminister wenn heute eine
erste einschätzung dieses große bild ist
noch ziemlich unscharf setzt sich
zusammen aus kleinen veränderungen im
leben von menschen aber von millionen
von menschen jeder für sich
florian neumann berichtet der weg zur
arbeit hat sich nicht geändert vieles
andere schon an diesem morgen eine
kleine premiere für thomas müller
es ist das erste mal seit drei monaten
wirklich im büro die bisher die ganze
zeit von zu hause gearbeitet
früher war der unternehmensberater
ständig unterwegs im büro oder bei
kunden seit krone aber sind viele
arbeitsplätze bei ernst & young quasi
sperrzone dienstreisen ersetzt durch
digitale sollten bleibt das jetzt so
genau das untersucht losse müller im
auftrag des bundesumweltministeriums
heute eine zwischenbilanz
die krone maßnahmen und die
gegenmaßnahmen haben verhaltensänderung
routinen wechsel erzwingen
die viele leute positiv finden deswegen
wird das auch dauerhaft so seien
langfristig so die studie werde die zahl
der geschäftsreisen vermutlich um 30
prozent sinken verglichen mit der zeit
vor corona der verkehr allgemein um
immerhin acht prozent als im märz der
korona tiefschlaf beginnt erlebt das
land an der digitalisierung schub der
sonst wohl jahre gedauert hätte der
datenverkehr stark demselben monat
sprunghaft um zehn prozent so viel wie
sonst in einem jahr
digital von zu hause aus arbeiten in
vielen behörden und unternehmen vorher
ein riesenaufwand plötzlich der norm
auch im umweltministerium von svenja
schulze die heute aber auch auf klima
risiken des digitalen hinweist
der schub den wir im datenverkehr
gesehen haben der ist ja nur ein vorbote
für mehr
ich gehöre nicht zu denen die sagen er
streaming ist es neues liegen im
gegenteil dennoch müssen wir in all
diesen bereichen fortschritte machen
wenn wir den klimaschutz wirklich wenn
wir die klimaziele erreichen wollen
schon jetzt sorgt das internet weltweit
für 800 millionen tonnen co2 ausstoß in
einem jahr
das ist etwa so viel wie deutschland
insgesamt produziert oder mit der
flugverkehr weltweit vor der krise und
trotzdem dürfte die klimabilanz der
korona zeit deutlich positiv ausfallen
und uns sagt der soziologe harald welzer
etwas lehren für kommende krisen was uns
das ganze zeigt ist dass veränderung
doch viel schneller möglich ist als wir
es im normalen von totalen
interessengegensätze gekennzeichneten
politikbetrieb haben wo man immer denkt
da geht ja gar nix und siehe da wenn man
es will wenn der politische wille da es
geht unheimlich viel
nur in einem punkt erlebt das land
gerade sagen die daten der
zwischenbilanz klimatechnisch einen
rückfall während der öffentliche
nahverkehr vielerorts noch so leer
bleibt wie zu beginn der krise sind die
straßen längst wieder dicht aus angst
vor ansteckung nehmen die deutschen
wieder öfter das auto insgesamt so
häufig wie vor der krise
black live eine selbstverständlichkeit
wie ein schlachtruf wurde bei den großen
demonstrationen in den usa sie findet
widerhall in aller welt schwarze leben
zählen und gelbe braune weiße und alle
zwischen farbtöne auch in deutschland
und auch in deutschland nicht immer
sicher im schlaglicht der großen
proteste erscheinen jetzt auch defizite
deutscher polizeien und strafverfolger
wieder in schärfere konturen die übel
nach vorurteilen riechenden
ermittlungsfehler bei der mord serie des
nsu die hass botschaften aus einer
polizeistation gegen eine frankfurter
anwältin mit türkischem namen
polizeimaßnahmen
kontrollen zb die wohl von der hautfarbe
der betroffenen gelenke sind unter denen
die daraus auf latenten rassismus unter
polizisten öffentlich schlossen ist der
spd vorsitzende saskia esken sie es
stellte sich heute der polizei in
hannover in akademischen rahmen peter
kunst berichtet
polizei und politik teilen sich die
ersten drei buchstaben
ansonsten kann man sich durchaus
entzweien also führte der
niedersächsische spd innenminister
pistorius heute beides zusammen seine
bundesvorsitzende nahm und gab in der
polizeiakademie nienburg nachhilfe ich
glaube dass der besuch dazu gedacht ist
dass ich was dazulernen und das andere
lernen zu verstehen was ich gemeint
haben dass wir um so zu einem guten
austausch kommen
gespannte zuhörer vielleicht auch
gespannte stimmung viele beamte haben
sich empört über eskens generalverdacht
die diskussion mit den studierenden dann
ohne medienbegleitung
es ist ja so dass wir öfter mal als
querschnitt der gesellschaft bezeichnet
werden
aber schon beim einstellungsverfahren da
sieben wir durchaus teile der
gesellschaft aus und wenn jetzt ein
studierender der hier noch ein sehr
wackliges beamtenverhältnis hat wenn der
dabei erwischt wird wir irgendwas so in
richtung rassismus fremdenfeindlichkeit
was mit unseren werten aus nicht
vereinbar ist tätig dann wird ja auch
mal ganz schnell wegen charakterlicher
eignung entlassen
mit meinen kollegen bin ich immer super
ausgekommen natürlich gab es negative
momente auch mal im kontakt mit den
bürgern
das passiert aber insgesamt würde ich
dahingehend auf jeden fall untermauern
dass es in der polizei in meiner
wahrnehmung weniger probleme für mich
gab als außerhalb polizisten sollen uns
die heile welt bewahren unsere helfer
seien aber manchmal auch das gegenteil
über den unterschied darf aber nicht die
herkunft entscheiden sondern das
polizeiliche lagebild da reicht das
natürlich nicht aus wenn jemand eine
dunkle hautfarbe hat wenn jemand
asiatisch aussieht oder was auch für
immer für auffälligkeiten aufweist
tatsächlich geht es darum ein komplexes
lagebild und diese abwägung ist dann
natürlich eine komplett andere und da
spielen auch andere
tore rein wie ort zeit raum und die
allgemeine kriminalitätslage natürlich
so ideal wie auf der akademie ist es
aber auf der straße nicht immer es gibt
die grauzone von gewalt und rassismus
ich glaube der polizei fällt es schwer
wenn das thema auf den tisch kommt und
wenn es fälle gibt
über die eine gesellschaft diskutiert
wird diesen widerspruch auszuhalten
zwischen dem eigenen selbstbild dem
eigenen selbstverständnis und den fakt
dass es das problem in der polizei aber
eben doch gibt traf die spd-vorsitzende
also doch einen nerv eines ist aber ganz
klar polizeibeamtinnen und -beamte wohl
keine rassisten in ihren reihen das ist
mir nicht erst heute klar geworden dass
es diese fälle gibt schmerz niemanden
mehr als sie die diesen beruf doch
ergriffen haben und unsere werte unsere
rechtsordnung auch zu verteidigen
politik und polizei müssen zur
verteidigung mehr gemein haben als nur
die ersten drei buchstaben vertrauen
muss sie verbinden
es ist fronleichnam heute anders als der
name des feiertags vermuten lässt
gedenken katholiken gar nicht des toten
sondern des lebendigen jesus und
trotzdem gehen nach so einer prozession
viele doch noch auf den friedhof an die
gräber ihrer lieben so war das seit
jahrhunderten
es ändert sich wie sich der umgang mit
den toten ändert impressionen vom rallye
wohin führt der letzte weg
welche sehnsüchte begleiten ihn welche
hoffnung
die lassen wir menschen gehen wie wollen
wir heute selber gehen eine welt im
wandel
auch hier
der tod aus der gesellschaft aus dem
leben wird im prinzip ausgeklammert
niemand in der familie beschäftigt sich
mit dem tod jeder möchte das beste
machen aber wenig dafür tun
das bedeutet pflegeintensive
familiengräber drohen auszusterben und
mit ihnen alte rituale traditionen
gräber kult auf dem friedhof im
thüringischen ronneburg gibt es fast
keine erdbestattungen mehr die leere
flächen sind riesig und spiegeln eine
bundesweite entwicklung
experten sprechen bereits von einer
friedhofs flucht denn die gesellschaft
verändert sich drastisch zentrale
entwicklungen sind zum beispiel das was
wir so die die freisetzung der menschen
nennen also meinen distanziert sich von
der familie von dem herkunftsort
vielleicht auch von prägenden
kulturellen elementen und das hat dann
eben effekte auf dem toten acker das
heißt da ist dann das grab der
großmutter in hamburg die tochter wurde
in berlin der sohn in münchen
das ist konstellation die wir ganz oft
sehen so geht der trend immer mehr zur
alternativen bestattungsformen das meer
oder ruhe wälder wie hier in nordrhein
westfalen
nicole kaiser ist einzelkind voll
berufstätig für sich und ihre eltern
kaufte sie eine alte eiche als letzte
ruhestätte
über ihren urnen im waldboden werden
sich eines tages die äste mit ihrem
blätter und lichtspiel wölben
dieses bild dieses gefühl war wichtig
für ihre gemeinsame entscheidung
hier bin ich groß geworden ich kenne ihn
bald auch schon von kind an und
verbindet damit verschiedene erlebnisse
und dadurch dass wir uns dem baum hat
vorab ausgesucht haben
hat man da auch eine ganz andere
beziehung zu als wenn man eine
grabstätte hat wo man auf einmal nur
dieses grab sieht und dass das erste mal
bei der beerdigung sieht das ist ganz
anderes gefühl
kommunale friedhöfe treibt dieser wandel
zunehmend in finanzielle engpässe
dabei waren und sind jedoch mehr als nur
eine toten städte sie sind kultur archiv
ein stück heimat grüne lunge
doch auch die bestatter spüren immer
deutlicher dass die verbindung vieler
menschen zur kirche im angesicht des
todes verloren geht
die kirchen waren der bewahrer der
rituale wenn man an die toten gedenktage
denkt im november also volkstrauertag
allerseelen ja das ist heute nicht mehr
das was früher war auch deshalb
eröffnete der quirlige rheinländer ein
sogenanntes indoor kolumbarium
hinterbliebene können hier die ohren in
ihrer verstorbenen zu jeder zeit tag und
nacht besuchen
für klaus frankenheim passt das konzept
in die zeit die gräber sind individuell
wetter geschützt und pflegeleicht die
deutsch-chinesischen
wirtschaftsbeziehungen in zeiten von
corona waren thema einer video konferenz
von bundeskanzlerin merkel und chinas
ministerpräsident
zudem ging es merkel auch um einen
besseren zugang zum chinesischen markt
und die gleichbehandlung deutscher und
anderer ausländischer unternehmen in
china gegenüber ministerpräsident
letizia machte sie deutlich dass dafür
weitere schritte nötig seien
weitere themen waren die lage in
hongkong und die der menschenrechte im
skandal um mangelhafte silikon
brustimplantate ist eine patientin aus
deutschland mit ihrer klage vor dem
europäischen gerichtshof gescheitert
die richter entschieden dass kein
schadenersatzanspruch bestehe die
versicherung dürfe den haftpflichtschutz
auf bestimmte länder hierauf frankreich
beschränken der deutschen klägerin war
ein implantat des französischen
herstellers bp eingesetzt worden
das unternehmen hatte jahrelang
minderwertiges silikon verwendet
katholiken in ganz deutschland haben
also fronleichnam gefeiert wegen des
corona virus wurden die traditionellen
prozessionen allerdings fast überall
abgesagt
im münchner liebfrauendom würdigte
kardinal marx in seiner predigt die
vielen menschen die in der korona
pandemie den kranken und notleidenden
geholfen haben
aufgrund der strengen
hygienevorschriften durften nur 70
gläubige am gottesdienst teilnehmen
unter ihnen viele pflege und seelsorgern
corona leichtsinn weniger regeln mehr
ärger das ist die leitfrage gleich bei
maybrit illner unter den gästen der arzt
und kanzleramtsminister helge braun und
der virologe hindrik strikt wir wünschen
weiterführende erkenntnisse und nehmen
die felgen des tages morgen hier wieder
auf schönen abend
[Musik]
ein schulamt und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter aus dem osten erreichte uns
continental luft aber dies ziemlich
feucht und ist ordentlich geladen und so
gibt es zum wochenende dann teilweise
unwetterartige gewitter
schon morgen gibt es erste gewitter hier
im osten deutschlands und die können
auch durchaus platzregen mitbringen
schauen wir uns an wie die wärme da aus
dem osten zu uns gelangt und zu sehen
hier schlagartig fast gelangt diese
wärme einmal komplett über deutschland
hinweg nach westen und so werden die
werte 25 bis 30 grad morgen erreichen
schauen wir uns das ganze mal im detail
an in der nacht gibt es im norden viele
wolken und es regnet ansonsten ist es
meist sternenklar vor allem nach süden
hin und die temperaturen sinken auf 14
15 grad ganz im norden an den küsten und
6 grad am alpenrand
morgen dann im tagesverlauf viel
sonnenschein nach norden hin mehr wolken
vor allem an den küsten und zum
nachmittag dann schauer und gewitter von
westen her
und die können schon kräftigen regen
mitbringen aber ansonsten sehr viel
sonne im süden bei temperaturen bis 30
grad also es gibt einen satten sprung
nach oben bei den werten von heute auf
morgen
ja und das geht dann auch so weiter am
samstag bis 30 grad dann aber
unwetterartige gewitter teils mit
platzregen sturmböen und hagel und diese
gewitter die sich hier bilden die ziehen
kaum weiter also die unwettergefahr ist
hier groß sonntag dann mehr nach mitte
zur mitte hin und das bei werten bis 28
grad
damit ein schöner abend